YOU GET UP SMARTER.
>> Laura: YOU BE THE JUDGE.
>> I NEVER TOUCHED ANYONE
INAPPROPRIATELY OR MADE
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL ADVANCES.
>> I DID NOT HAVE SEXUAL
RELATIONS WITH THAT WOMAN.
>> GIVE THAT MAN A CIGAR.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
[LAUGHING].
>> [CHEERING].
>> Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY.
IF YOU REMEMBER NEWTON'S LAW.
NOT THAT NEWTON.
THIS NEWTON.
THERE WE GO.
WHEW!
THAT WENT OVER REALLY WELL.
ISAAC NEWTON SAID THAT FOR EVERY
ACTION THERE IS AN EQUAL AND
OPPOSITE REACTION LIKE MY
NIGHTLY MASSAGE THERAPIST FORCES
COME IN PARIS.
THIS IS FEAR AND RESPONSE TO IT
FEAR.
THE BULLET SHORTAGE IS SO BAD
GANG BANGERS LIMIT SHOOTINGS TO
BYSTANDERS WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED.
AS FIRE ARM SALES JUMPED BY 20
MILLION LAST YEAR, THE.
>> A NEW GENERATION OF SUPER
SOAKER.
TWICE THE CALIBER.
>> Greg: YES, IF YOU ARE
SURPRISED, YOU MUST BE SURPRISED
BY SUN RISES OR TAX DAYS OR HOW
DUMB JOY BEHAR IS.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: THAT GETS APPLAUSE.
ANYONE WITH HALF A BRAIN COULD
SEE THIS COMING.
OR HALF A BRAIN IN TOTAL.
THE RUN ON GUNS IS A DIRECT
RESPONSE TO A FEAR.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN THE SALE
INCREASE IN PLYWOOD AFTER THE
RIOTS.
THE MEDIA WILL GET YOU WORKED
OVER ANY IMAGINARY CRISIS.
GROWING VIOLENT CRIME, YOU HEAR
CRICKETS.
IT'S THE MEDIA DENIAL THAT FUELS
THE GUN MINNIAN.
-- MANIA.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN HUNTER
BIDEN SAYING WHAT DRUG PROBLEM?
TURN ON THE LOCAL NEWS.
A WOMAN SUCKER PUNCHED ON THE
STREET AND A WOMAN DIES AFTER
A BRUTAL MUGGING.
THE NATIONAL NEWS RUNS FROM THE
STORY LIKE A FEMALE STAFFER
RUNNING FROM ANDREW CUOMO.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: AND THESE CRIME WAVES
ARE SOMEHOW ACCEPTABLE BECAUSE
IT'S FINE WITH THE RULING CLASS.
NOT A LOT OF STREET CRIME AT A
PARTY IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THIS HAS PEOPLE LIKE ME BUYING
GUNS FOR PROTECTION.
I CAN'T GO ON CERTAIN CARNIVAL
RIDES BUT BUYING A GUN IS
A SNACHLT I LOVE THIS COUNTY.
THE GUN STORE SHELVES ARE AS
EMPTY AS KAT'S MEDICINE CABINET
AFTER A LONG WEEKEND.
WHAT IS FUELLING THIS RIDE?
.
LAW ABIDING WOMEN ARE BUYING
GUNS.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
IT'S "GUTFELD!"'S RULE:
BUYING A GUN IS A GATEWAY DRUG
TO LEAVING LEFTIM.
THE MEDIA AND DEMS ARE DRIVING
GUNS SALES UP EVEN MORE.
THE MEDIA WILL USE A VAGUE
PHRASE, GUN VIOLENCE TO
NATIONALIZE THE ISSUE AND
CALLING CRIME A LOCAL ISSUE.
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU SAW
A BANG GANGER WITH 10 BUCKS
TRIED TO THEIR ESCALADE.
THEY FOCUS ON THE LAW ABIDING
LIKE REMAKING JAWS WITH
SWIMMERS.
LAW ABIDING PEOPLE WILL GO BY
THE LAW THAT ARE MADE BUT THE
CRIMINALS WON'T.
THIS IS PART OF A GREATER
MISSION TO REMAKE SOCIETY INTO
SOMETHING NEW BY DESTROYING IT
FIRST.
WHAT DOES THAT DO?
WELL, NEWTON SAID WHAT GOES UP
MUST COME DOWN.
THE MORE DEMS TRY TO REDUCE YOUR
SECURITY ITS UP TO THE REST OF
US TO ENHANCE IT.
BY 2022 WE WILL ALL BE DRIVING
TANKS.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> [CHEERING].
>> Greg: SHE IS SO SOUTHERN SHE
BRUSHES HER TEETH WITHOGRAPHY.
-- GRAVY.
DAGEN MCDOWELL.
AND CLAY TRAVIS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SHE IS LIKE A MOTH
DRAWN TO BRIGHT LIGHTS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT.
AND A FEDERAL CRIME FOR HIM TO
POP ON A POGO STICK.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: THE STORY CAME OUT WE
ARE RUNNING OUT OF AMON.
PEOPLE NOT FAMILIAR WITH GUNS
HOW MUCH AMMO DO YOU NEED?
YOU NEED A LOT.
BECAUSE AMMO MAKES BETTER
SHOOTERS FOR TRAINING PURPOSES.
>> AND HUGE CONCERN FOR THE 8
MILLION NEW GUN OWNERS WHO
PURCHASED WEAPONS.
YOU NEED TO GO TO THE RANGE AND
LEARN HOW TO SHOOT.
WHERE I COME FROM, IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A MASSIVE STOCKPILE OF AMMO
THAT'S A POX TO YOUR FAMILY.
SAYING THE BARBECUE IN BROOKLYN
IS AWESOME.
THEY LOCK THE DOOR IF THAT'S THE
WAY YOU ROLL.
CALLING UP A FRIEND ASKING FOR
EXTRA AMMO THEY WILL TELL YOU TO
CAMPOUT IN A TENT IN FRONT OF
GUN STORES WHICH IS HAPPENING.
>> Greg: IF I WALKED OVER TO
A NEIGHBOR WITH A CUP AND ASK DO
YOU HAVE ANY SPARE BULLETS?
>> NO, THEY DON'T HAVE GUNS IN
WEST CHESTER.
THEY WILL SET THEIR ALARM WHEN
THEY SEE YOU IN THEIR YARD.
I HAVE AN UPDATE.
I GOT A LOT OF MY FRIENDS ON THE
PHONE FOR THIS.
THE SHORTAGES ARE EASY FOR
COMMON CALIBERS.
PRICES ARE STILL HIGH.
WHERE IS THE DAMN GREEN SCREEN?
REMMINGTON BACK ONLINE IN THE
SPRING.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT A PRIMER
SHORTAGE.
IT WAS NOT LEAD OR RAW
MATERIALS.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: NONE OF US HAVE TO
RECYCLE OUR BULLETS?
>> THAT'S POSITIVE.
I WAS ALSO RAISED IN THE SOUTH.
THEY GIVE YOU GUNS AT EARLY
AGES.
PEOPLE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THINK THAT'S CRAZY FOR 8
YEARS OLD.
THE BEST BOOM FOR BULLET SALES
IS THE RIDICULOUS ARGUMENT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE.
EVERYBODY OUT THERE WHO HAS
A FUNCTIONAL BRAIN KNEW WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
CRIME WOULD SKY ROCKET.
CRIMINALS DON'T FOLLOW GUN LAWS
ALREADY.
CHANGING THEM DOESN'T HELP.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT OURSELVES.
8 MILLION NEW GUN OWNERS WHO
WOULD HAVE NEVER CONSIDERED
BUYING GUNS IS HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE.
I THINK THE DEMAND WILL GROW.
>> Greg: I THINK SO.
I ASKED YOU HOW MANY GUNS YOU
HAVE.
HAS IT INCREASED SINCE 2 WEEKS
AGO?
>> YES.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I AM A PROUD NEW DADDY OF
A PISTOL GRIP SHOTGUN.
IT'S SWEET.
IT'S PHENOMENAL.
WHAT ELSE IS PHENOMENAL.
THERE ARE TIMES IN LIFE WHEN
WORKING FOR FOX NEWS YOU GET THE
DIRT LOOK OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
NOT IN A GUN STORE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WE HAVE SHOULD THINGS IN THE
BACK!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THERE WAS A LONG LINE FOR
AMMUNITION.
HE IS LIKE.
HOW MANY BOXES DO YOU NEED?
I COME BACK WITH HOW MUCH YOU
GOT?
TALLER THAN YOU.
I WALK IN WITH HEAVIAR TILLERY.
I HAVE TO THANK THE LEFT.
YOU DEFUND THE POLICE AND
FINANCE THE NRA AND THE GUN SHOP
OWNERS WERE SHUTTING DOWN.
THERE WERE 2 THAT CLOSED DOWN.
THEY ARE BACK NOW.
BECAUSE YOU DEFUNDED THE POLICE
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE TO RAISE
MILITIAS JUST TO WALK THROUGH
OUR STREETS AND KEEP THINGS
FACE.
>> Greg: AMMO IS PRECIOUS, KAT.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS?
IS THIS A GOOD OR BAD
DEVELOPMENT?
>> IT'S A DEVELOPMENT.
I WOULD GO SO FAR AS TO SAY.
THAT I THINK THAT MORE PEOPLE
BECOMING FIRST TIME GUN BUYERS
IS A GOOD THING.
I THINK THEY MAYBE UNDERSTAND, I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROTECT MYSELF
IN ANY SITUATION.
ALSO THE BAD THING WOULD BE IN
THIS SITUATION, YOU HAVE BEEN
GIVEN NO CHOICE.
THE LAWMAKERS REMOVING POLICE
PROTECTION AND HIRING PRIVATE
SECURITY FOR THEMSELVES IN THEIR
OWN HOMES.
MAYBE THEY WERE FEEDING ME SOME
[BLEEP].
THEN YOU BUY A GUN.
THE [BLEEP] THAT LED TO IS BAD
BUT OPENING YOUR EYES TO THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS A GOOD
THING.
>> Greg: HEARING WOMEN ARE
PURCHASING MORE GUNS IS A VERY
GOOD SIGN.
LEARNING TO USE IT.
GETTING BEYOND THAT BARRIER.
BECAUSE IT'S A GUY THING.
SOME OF THE BEST SHOOTERS ARE